you know i knew that what is a woman is
going to be a stumper of a question for
these people but what i didn't quite
realize is that um leading up to that
question really any question at all
is a stumper
and this is what makes them so angry
they're supposed to make declarations
and proclamations and i'm supposed to
sit in slack-jawed awe
nodding my head submissively
accepting without question everything
that comes out of their mouths the
moment they realized that i wasn't going
to play my part in that
game
they became angry i'm just trying to
start by getting to the truth yeah i
mean i'm really uncomfortable with that
language of like getting to the truth
who can't handle the truth why is that
uncomfortable because that it sounds
actually deeply transphobic to me um you
keep invoking the word truth which is
condescending and rude i was being
condescending and rude he says the good
professor couldn't define the word woman
probably also couldn't define the word
projection though he certainly exhibited
the latter throughout our interaction